is you you know when you're doing
something right and you know when
something feels right when you get that
feeling you have to keep following it
here's an example okay so when I sold my
business so my first business was a
biotech software company that was one
what they give you in bucks a month I
built it up sold it a couple years and
when I sold my business I didn't know
what I wanted to do next like that was
my first success story I didn't know
what I wanted to do next I got invited
by a YMCA in Toronto to speak to their
group of entrepreneurs and I thought wow
this would be really cool I've never
done a lot of speaking I think this
might be a good opportunity for me to
help other people just want to give back
I didn't know there'd be any business
model behind it and for the next two
weeks I worked really hard on making my
presentation and the slides and then
just putting all the stuff I wanted to
talk about into this presentation
and I was promoting to the people I knew
and the YMCA was pointed to people that
they knew and in their program people
signed up for this program this is a
free event right I wasn't making
anything free come out for free just
just to learn I remember the day comes
and I'm nervous and I'm excited and my
heart's beating and and I wake up in the
morning I'm looking over my presentation
to make sure that everything is just as
I want it you know I wanted to be
perfect and really help these people out
and I get to the building and my heart's
beating and I'm just you know sweating a
little bit I get to the elevator I walk
up and we spend all this time promoting
this event preparing for it I get into
this big room we had lined it up full of
chairs and three people showed up three
people you know my heart like stopped
like what where is everybody
you know we promoted this free event my
audience their audience where was
everybody and after I you know was got
over my shock I said you know what I
took the time to make this presentation
three people took the time out of their
lives to come and see me so I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this presentation and
it was awesome and I knew I really
helped those three people that day and
this is another great example of
listening to your head versus your heart
because for for everybody if you look at
that situation from an out
cider if you look at that you say Evan
what are you doing like you spent all
this time making this presentation you
wasted two weeks of your life you
promoted it a free event and nobody
shows up this is this isn't gonna work
this is a stupid idea you can't turn
this into anything look at look at what
you did here just go do the safe thing
and do something else but I felt so good
coming out of that presentation I had
this high that knowing that I help these
people that I just knew I had to find a
way to keep doing it even if I wasn't
gonna make money at it
I didn't have it all worked out I just
had to find the way to keep going and
again I would feel like if I didn't keep
doing this I would I would live with
regret like I wish I had given a little
bit more ice maybe that's the way to
answer the question maybe that's the way
you listened to your your heart is you
know if you don't do this if you don't
go down that path will you aggress this
10 years later 20 years later 30 years
later